chérie c'est très simple je le terre des
boulettes de papier à pour chacun
d'entre vous allez jeter la boulette
dans la poubelle
si vous y arrivez tout va bien si vous
n'y arrivez pas il y aura votre gage et
on le découvrira une fois que vous
n'aurez pas mais la boulette
voilà voulez vous qu'ils avaient chaussé
vous quoi voilà c'est vous qui l'avez
choisi le gage vous avez vu ce qu'il
avait écrit son nom le découvrir après
mais moi je le sais vous savez que c'est
moi qui ai pris par l'émotion que
d'habitude c'est pas lui qui choisit le
savez quoi tu leur mets tu vois qui je
suis
bonsoir salut tu vas bien bah ça fait
plaisir toujours toujours dans le besoin
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas de hasard mais s'il ya du
hasard qu'à réussir à mettre la boulette
ça mais si tu réussis à m alors oui
excusez moi et vous qui dit je vous
demande juste un truc
la boulette vous l'ajoutez vous ne
mangez pas attention on va démarrer avec
raymond ray man ray rejoint de monsieur
lennon
claire villemant par mois et vous verrez
moment gages il et il est chaud du coup
il a pas de hasard si vous savez ce que
je tenais bien moi avec gp le trait
exprès attention mais devant ses
adversaires à la cuillère non
le vent s'était bâti sait combien donna
c'est un essai s'était terminé merci au
revoir
alors tout raymond s'engage s'est pas
concentré dégage sympa riac dh pour eux
non plus s'il vous plaît il ya des gages
pourri c'est normal oui on n'est pas là
pour faire plaisir
alors attention vraiment on va voir une
vidéo et ce sera ton gage regard de
raymond cette vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vas nous en faire la spi galoche
alors est-ce qu'il arrive après mais
voilà ce qui lui a apprécié et très cher
si tu vas devoir embrasser boulot est
fait quoique aspirateur avant on peut
dans l'aspirateur donc devoir on l'a mis
dans le cul de mathieu allez merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la bonne marche et donc des sommes
auxquelles j'ai un peso est les mecs
mais ça il sait pas non mais je les
bouchers il a bouché gélase pu prêter
enfin ça marche ça marche pas la salud
affirmé l'ong open series excuse moi tu
les responsables aspirateur si tu peux
toujours tu vas bien regarde regarde la
regarde regarde les bains vous n'avez
pas tous fait votre bouche mais non mais
non
alors ils sont prêts l'admirateur qui
marchait pas alors 1000 watts suffi sent
bon les chérir va faire un autre
attaquant truc alors ses pattes et
attention c'est parti
bon ça je range ou si vous voulez morne
alors inquiète des bombes allaient
chercher un aspirateur moi c'est abou ba
oui mais manier vous le cul allez c'est
parti ce soir alors est pas mal c'est je
suis en la ola
je suis prête à l'est concentre
attention voici votre boule est tu la
mettais un méthanier un regarde midi là
pour moi à l'intérieur
je ne mets jamais des boulettes dans une
poubelle non je joue pas grossi et au tu
vois la ligne et on dépose c'est ça
c'est nouveau ça mais allez vas-y
oh la la attention alors arrêter al air
[Applaudissements]
c tom castaldi trop court
[Rires]
merci et je peux témoigner
l'appel à la mecque qu'est ce que c'est
ça la chapelle à genlis a rappelé
olivier schrameck et dû faire un petit
coucou je t'ai pmp réalisez vous dit
bonjour c'est quelqu'un et shelly son
portable convenait pas mais pas avant
toi alors vous dites c'est christine
cadillon détente ou mac d'oc touche pas
à mon pote on voulait vous faire un
petit bisou et u8 santa biatra make way
non non non non non non je lui fais un
petit coucou opérations réalisées comme
des palpitations et en numéro masqué
noms numéros baisse qui perd sa raison
souple et non mais les scieries cross
mais alors oui j'espère qu'il va
décrocher une vous n'appelez pas en
numéro masqué vous appeler au numéro
démasqué mais je stresse qui va la
compagnie créole haïtien c'est pas le
bal masqué stress leur chance mais c'est
vous je sais très aguerris qui
décrochent olivier schrameck du regard
sinon vous lui laisse un vide et tu
seras l'aimé pas
c'est alors c'est bien sûr l'ancien
patron du set ecopolis fatigué bonsoir
mon cher président bonsoir mon cher
président christine kelly c'était juste
pour faire un bisou en direct de touche
pas à mon poste un peu sous la pression
je vous embrasse
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien ce jeu là ce que je veux
faire la paix à petit cette tournée je
t'ai bebo valdes entre et d'avenir oui
c'est entre valérie benguigui valérie
bénaïm venez me rejoindre
est ce que vous voulez bien les boules
alors attention benhaim oui je vous
donnerai votre gage juste apeuré juste
un peu rires je vous le donnerai mes
genre de phase one
merci thierry bayle celle ci soit la
pédagogie les nazis alors benhaim c'est
très simple vous avez vous mettre à
votre place vous inquiétez pas d'accord
et ben haim vous allez devoir 1 pour
votre gage chanté deux titres d'abricots
macias diack à 2 ou à des sites et
chanté des titres de henry corée macias
avec de l'haricot mais regardez vous
faites les chefs
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
laurent
faites juste ok ok quand sa clé dans la
paume à laquelle hadj benalla les bercy
mena
bravo non c'est gagné mais la télé dit
elle à sega lire attention
géraldine maillet venait à tien je vais
préparer votre boulet je rappelle que
son jouet des boulettes et des boulettes
et dégage 19h26 on est en direct voici
votre boulot merci labo bull l'a lâché
la boulette sinon il faudrait chercher
la boîte vous devez tweeté à salé ce que
je dois faire me devais twitté vrai gros
[ __ ] c'est est ce qu'on appelle un
twitter qui leur a alors dit moi je ne
fume pas je ne bois pas qu'est-ce que je
pète tout ça a tout de suite ouvert tout
au tout est ok je ne fume pas je ne bois
pas mais qu'est ce que je peux et y
voilà merci normalement c'est benjamin
qui donne l'impression qu'on va
enchaîner avec jean michel maire
on peut choisir sa noria unis c'est plus
là je pensais aller mais c'est pas un
gouffre attention non qui derrière louis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michel vous deviez verser un cocktail de
votre chaussure le boire ce qu'on
appelle le bouche à bouche
j'adore le vin rouge
attention kelly b novelli
[Applaudissements]
tenez calinon maria je suis derrière la
ligne non mais vas-y tu as quand même à
lille elle tourne tu te crois au dessus
des autres comme vous prenez au dessus
des autres un peu hâlé vélo velits et
feydeau vidéo on dirait qu'elle passe le
bac soit celle de ma mère a lancé votre
regard quand vous avez dû la feuille pas
du tout quel dommage galère je sais que
vous avez une passion dans la douce et
les licornes rester les racheteurs
s'adorer les licornes vous allez faire
la licorne exactement vous allez devoir
faire la nique en devant les
téléspectateurs vous savez imité un peu
le cheval c'est très simple alors je le
dis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un corner très variés je vous le
dis donc ne mangeait pas vous allez
devoir bien sûr le coller sur votre foi
que les bien fondus de faire le cheval
il est bien fondus fait le cheval enlève
ta franchise mais à bien ce soir des
packs attendait mais on n'est pas
obligés de prendre ça suffit pas si
jamais je faisais tout le temps oui mais
sceptique un effort à plus tard
[Applaudissements]
santé par la presse comme pouvant
l'amener à mais bien glacé s'il vous
plaît d'ailleurs n ont ni corps ni
restriction est joué que ces sujets
maintenant on a le tweet de géraldine
regarde et je ne compte pas je ne bois
pas mais qu'est ce que je peux être je
vais rater ma boulet année - accor est
tombé bien s'il est là ce qui n'est pas
classée andre agassi la halle et non
mais je ne peux pas et je n'ai pas j'en
ai insulté ce ne sera pas freiner
l'insurrection veut un glass et ça ne
marche plus il est vrai ont bien glacé
je le fais tout le temps là on va passer
maintenant à matthieu delormeau situe en
ce moment c'est à toi moi mathieu
delormeau on a dit la même mais giada
brut dans le panier ma fille en ce
moment je suis allée ma fille ma fille
mais laquelle vous dire alors vous je
vais changer un peu la mécanique
je me suis un peu la mécanique je vais
vous dire ce qui se passe si vous perdez
ah ah si vous ne mettez pas la boulette
mais qui vous dit rien vous allez devoir
me passer votre portable pendant toute
l'émission avec le code annonce pouvoir
répondre à tous les cm2 s'est rendu
personnellement sur toile et touchent
peu partout mais ça ne fait pas cela
alors pour l'instant venir ces
passionnés la casse avec le nom
d'ailleurs tu m'as fais ta carte bleue
ya opposition moi je fais mon portable
numéro un des noms m'a dit je te le tac
est pas là aussi tu vas le faire vas-y
hélas tamoule est attaqué par un bta
desquels toit et la caméra sur moi
non
[Applaudissements]
mais je sais pas ce gaz nazies sabres à
toi t'as même pas fait ton tout de
collagène pêche
[Applaudissements]
regardez bien les garder la coupe du
monde le mag
alors tu peux pas deviner des chiffres
là c'est pas bateau un truc c'est malin
mais c'est vrai ça va tous avaient un
texto sur toi exercer ce matin ma soeur
of the qui verra jamais taper le code
[Musique]
quelqu'un vous envoyer un texto ions
droit quelqu'un qui n'aime pas mais
s'était défendu ses gammes que tu fais
ton émission rigole et puis les textos
qui sont négatives sur toi mon téléphone
les filles malheur n'arrive même pas je
vais je vais je vais te dire ouais tu
vas me manquer ton portable il avait
frappé lors d'une heure voilà les vrais
en plus ça voulait regarder c'est comme
ça mais non bravo
[Applaudissements]
à voir c'est vrai t'as pas fait le
cheval
vous maniez le montrait la licorne a
gardé le mois pour ce soir vous avez de
la trappe sur le front des femmes à 81 7
et aux portois obama et coûté à ba tan
en rien le pauvre stade et à coudre
[Applaudissements]
je jouais pas bien le bateau s'appelle
bien il est souvent trompés mais le fait
qu'elle n'est pas dedans il n'a pas vu
ça aussi dans les pattes dans bon j'ai
pas vu tous les mois la branche irrite
engage à c'est le robert uc
alors je suis se mettre les lunettes et
la marque de rhum et orly robert hue
pour mettre sa tête dont de la poudre
verte
voilà la vraie vous vous retournerez si
vous allaitez assis vous retournerez bon
ça c'est dans ses cordes ans et je le
prépare je le prépare je ne paie pas
merci merci beaucoup mais pas dans la
bouche et aux bas je siège peut-être la
copine à moi ça va attaquer copie
alors oui je vais le faire pourquoi tant
de faux noms mais jamais dû naître qui
les comblent les mets ta tête dedans
c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
cette phase de reprise attention
isabelle morini-bosc quoi c'est quoi en
fait c'est quoi la peau de la super 13
ans goodson c'est à dire et on gaze
après ben mami toit n'avait rien mais
niamey le calme est devenu l'âme hier de
même espèce d'hormones c'est pas super
forme en v and b
[Applaudissements]
la ceni non non à laisser patrick groulx
total aura surtout il a fait c'est très
simple match mais c'est l'adaptation mon
mari un faux pas c'est forcément aller
choper isabelle se faire verser du thé
dans la bouche par une personne se
trouvant auteurs c'est ce qu'on a déjà
fait une fois bien oui j'adore ça
s'appelle le thé à la hauteur et à la
jsk beau test le thé oui mais le sac à
dos alors mettez vous l'amènerai c'était
pour l'arrêter allongez-vous du poste à
nice la bête ça va être la femme
allongée avec toi mais non mais non pas
avec lui ça se discute mais nos rebelles
avaient discuté en rien du tout discuté
alors apporter les treuils en tout cas
tu étais belle ma mine aujourd'hui rien
n'est parfait
vas-y c'est quoi ces brûlots août à
bouche
[Rires]
à nous quatre
[Applaudissements]
attention alors un doc gynéco ou la ola
abandonné déjà s'engage gâcher un [ __ ]
olala allait montrer la boule à la fois
pardon non maniant enlève tes lunettes
d'alors mais l'effort allait rentrer
chez lui c'est maintenant à moi mon gars
gillet ça si je mets la boulette il ne
se passera rien si je rate la boulette
je double le salaire de chacun ce soir
n'aura sa mère autant vous dire qu'ils
valent arrête jamais il à l'ouvrir mais
jamais les élections la mise mais non
c'est à dire je souhaite que vous
réussissiez
mais pas du tout c'est très simple si je
mets la boulette dans la poubelle
je double le salaire de tous les
chroniqueurs aujourd'hui non t'as gagné
ta green non si je la mets pas le double
cela tous les coins si je la mets c'est
bien rien mais on a un soutien la
normale on se quitte en bons termes
ah d'accord j'ai décidé
étant donné que même du doc gynéco a
réussi à mettre la boulette de le faire
les yeux bandés
c'est une bonne lancée
il m'a ilm attachées dans le dos voir
les deux gamins
et de la main gauche bandée je revois
ces brins eggert ce coup là alors là
c'est dingue je gagne de losail ce soir
attend les capable de gagner à les dons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la carte bleue hier là ce soir et c'est
avec l'oseille ça m'amuse pas on peut
voir ce qui s'est passé j'ai pas vu
célébrer tue pas vu est ce qu'on peut
revoir s'il vous plaît elle met
longtemps rires
alors ok j'avais loupé quelque chose de
l'alberta villandraut faire je veux le
refaire
non mais comment on fait pour les
doubles primes bah oui voilà c'était à
ubs comment il savait le comté par aman
tu leur as un jour sa double prime là je
fais vraiment à l'abri mais vraiment
quoi il a monté le truc il va gagner
malgré cette connerie encore par ici
refera
on se sent bien senti que j'arrive il
est plus très chaud pour toi c'est rien
[Musique]
presque un phare ralentit le soja sur la
manière dont gtb gagne en haïti je
double vote aux salaires ouais
[Applaudissements]